when people say relationship is hard the
only really hard part about of a good
relationship is just dealing with
oneself and making sure that you're
staying in that
mode of caretaking because i do believe
that if
one is mainly focused on taking good
care of the other person provided
they're also focused on taking good care
of you
to some extent and we're good at taking
care of ourselves everybody flourishes
everything gets better but no i don't
think i experienced that until fairly
recently um what do you think is the uh
secret to a successful relationship
there isn't just one but at at least at
in the top five is
master or at least be
good at
autonomic self-regulation know how to
calm yourself down
don't expect the like looking to
anything external to soothe yourself is
it puts you in a terrible position to to
be a caretaker of yourself and other
people right so learn how to self-soothe
right learn how to
calm your mind steady your actions
steady your voice there are tools to do
that we talk about on the podcast but
elsewhere have that in place i also
think that if
if your main focus is on
you want to have good boundaries etc but
on
tending to the relationship doing a
little bit more than you think you ought
to do if everyone does that it goes
great i mean i'm sometimes so positively
struck by how supported i feel
um
because for many years i was just kind
of doing everything on my own so any
little thing i'm like oh my goodness
this feels huge
and also i think the dynamics have to be
right let's let's be really honest this
is a little bit of a tricky topic but um
there is a power dynamic in
relationships
sometimes not all but in some
relationships it works much better if
one person leads and the other person
follows in other relationships it's more
mutuality works best people need to know
what they need and so knowing what you
need and what you crave
is really important and then once you do
that you can
create the relationship you want i've
seen that over and over again and people
are different
um but i think that um
ultimately i mean right it's it's
there's the dopamine phase of a
relationship and then there's the
serotonin phase the kind of more
mutuality coziness and sweetness there's
a great book about how to make sure that
the dopamine component and the
serotonin component so to speak go on
forever and it has to do with you know
when you first meet someone you're
attracted to them you're essentially
objectifying them you meaning not in the
way people might think you are
not dependent on them for emotional
stability or survival as you get close
with somebody you really come to depend
on them and then you tend to objectify
them less and so this book the book is
the name is kind of corny but it's
written by an analyst again it's called
can love last and it's a book about how
really good strong relationships are the
consequence of people constantly moving
through this
dependency objectification dynamic
and i use those words in the true
the psychological sense not in the way
they're typically thrown around nowadays
so the id you know in some cultures
men and women
will
only touch for two weeks out of the
month
and then for the other two weeks
the
excitement and the sensuality and all
and the sexuality is very heightened
and then they go back to this kind of
distancing now i don't think that's
feasible for most people but if you look
statistically those relationships tend
to last a very long time with at least
reported
mutual feelings of intense attraction
for
many many many decades so
human beings need to learn how to
at least understand and control these
dynamics there's a lot of divorce
there's a lot of cheating there's a lot
of stuff out there it'd be great if
people could resolve some of this stuff
inside of the relationship in my opinion
yeah and this kind of intense attraction
i
there's uh actually uh one of the poems
that carl
uh daiseroth introduced me to i think
two english poems is the name but
one of the
things i find myself for prolonged
periods being attracted to
is like
you notice some kind of magic
and you keep wanting to dig to the
depths like
of that magic you're trying to really
know that person to really know a person
deeply yeah
you notice something yeah early on sure
i don't know what that is but you just
notice something special and you want to
keep pulling at that thread
and you never really do well you also
have to be careful you know i get a lot
of questions from god you have to be
careful the questions you ask in a
relationship too you have to make sure
you really want that information and
it's not just about people's past right
if you ask somebody how they really feel
about something about you and they tell
you
that may be soothing it may be intensely
stressful you have to be
here's one thing i know for sure
for a relationship to work you have to
be brave you can't go in there fully
protected and yet you also can't go in
there with no boundaries because you'll
end up
beat up what's that quote if you want to
be a warrior prepare to get hurt if you
want to be an explorer prepared to get
lost and if you want to be both you know
and if you become a lover prepare to
beat both or something something like
that i forget this is one of these
instagram type things that you see
passing by and you know it's pretty true
love love scary because it takes us back
to that primitive circuitry that is as
primitive and basic as hunger thirst the
desire for heat when we're cold the
desire for cold when we're
overly warm
it's a
it's dinorphin i mean when somebody
leaves like the you know when somebody
you were attached to leaves by death or
by decision
or you're forced apart the dynorphin
release is massive it is true discomfort
people
feel anxiety and discomfort and moving
through that is a hell of a process i
mean if i knew how to best break up at a
neurological level or if you could just
plug yourself into a wall and reset
i mean i'd i'd do that episode tomorrow
but we don't have that knowledge
come on the uh i think we've covered
this before and it's even been mimified
i think losing love is part of the magic
of love it means you've felt something i
agree but at some point like have you
done it enough times
you know
life is finite you know it is beautiful
to see these couples
that seem very much in love
despite
many years despite having been together
many years yeah the way they look at
each other yeah they'll say they still
see the magic yeah and they'll say we
got lucky or it was it's been hard or
this and that i think external
conditions being a little tougher is
helpful for a couple
hardship i do i do because i think that
you rally you know you you and you bond
with people you know being obviously you
want to survive those conditions but um
yeah i do i think that bonnie and clyde
so and they were a little
a little too much
well a little bit too much they were
sociopaths but the uh well when two
sociopaths [ __ ] can make you do crazy
normally it's interesting normally
sociopaths don't team up
because they because they manipulate
each other
sociopaths sadly are um are usually only
interested in manipulating the highly
pliable or unsuspecting
but when romantic attraction is woven in
then it gets
really diabolical
you